I don't even think women have such
amazing rights anyways we live in a very
misogynistic oh no we do not
child in terms of when it comes to court
cases they're more likely to get the
child but really what does what does a
woman have that women are built up women
are literally built out of every bad
decision that we make like every single
one if we sleep around there's birth
control if we if we get pregnant there's
abortion if we don't want to get
abortion if we don't want if we don't
want to get an abortion and we want to
live off of the government they'll pay
for our housing like literally every bed
if we're homeless there's women's
shelters so there's not men's shelters
they're just homeless